Wow old Deuteronomy we don't even know
where to start what is going on with
your Jellico's everyone knew that Katz
was going to be a unique experience when
the first trailer dropped last July but
we didn't quite expect as many
uncomfortable moments as we got honestly
you were one of the best parts of the
movie
you totally leaned into the weirdness of
being a CGI cat but the cats you preside
over are strange and we had to cringe
more than a few times the cats out of
the bag and the reviews are in cats is
one strange cinematic experience but it
takes the weirdness to an uncomfortable
level keep watching to see the 10 most
cringe-worthy moments from the cat's
movie the opening act let's start at the
very beginning the movie wastes no time
in letting us know exactly what we're in
for
the opening number of cats is a song
called Jellico songs for Jellicle cats
it explains exactly what the Jellicle
gang is and introduces a bunch of
characters we find out that there is a
Jellicle ball to determine who gets to
go to the Heaviside lair which is
basically heaven it's important for
understanding the plot of cats but this
number is wild in the movie version the
cast of the movie is full of super
famous actors and singers like rebel
Wilson James Corden and Jason Derulo but
all these characters are introduced so
quickly it will give you whiplash
there's no real cohesion in their
interactions Plus this number is
choreographed in a way that will make
you feel very uncomfortable the dance
moves are extremely suggestive but
you're always aware you're watching
anthropomorphic cats this opening act
feels like it's about to take an x-ray
to turn at any moment it doesn't but
it's definitely more adult than it needs
to be rum tum tugger the adult themes
continue throughout the movie and it's
pretty off-putting the film seems to
play up the suggestive moments in a way
than this stage musical never did the
underlying inappropriate feeling made a
lot of people cringe in their seats one
of the most obvious sensual components
is the entire character of rum tum
tugger this cat is played by Jason
Derulo no one can deny that Jason is a
talented singer and dancer but when you
make him a cat things get bizarre he's
got a flirtatious nature even down to
his hat and cane his song the rum tum
tugger is more than suggestive he moves
like me
dagger in a way that isn't appealing
because he's a CAD we don't know if this
was supposed to make people feel good or
uncomfortable it's a bit of a satire and
commentary about pop singers being
overly inappropriate this cat knows he
is something special and he plays it up
but it comes across in a way that will
make you squirm the bedroom scene
there's a scene in the movie where
several of the cats are in a ritzy
bedroom they totally destroy it in a way
that pet owners will find familiar but a
lot of the scene is unnecessarily weird
there are some comedic moments like when
they try to walk in human shoes the down
pillows get ripped apart and need us
worry our cats were at home getting into
trouble but then things took a turn they
try on the human's undergarments why it
felt personal and too intimate and the
sensual undertones were just a little
too much then Victoria the main cat gets
really into it Victoria is a young naive
cat who wants to go to the Heaviside
lair and her youth makes the scene even
more uncomfortable she lays back on the
bed while another cat puts jewelry over
her chest and she might be a cat but
it's clear that she's a girl if you know
what we mean the expression she makes as
she lays on the bed look like something
else is happening CGI and special
effects computer-generated animation can
be really cool it's helped usher
Hollywood into a new era of advanced
graphics but cats is proof that too much
CGI can be a bad thing the critics have
attacked the CGI for being just too much
in many scenes it's very off-putting in
stage versions of cats it's very clear
that the actors are humans playing cats
but the CGI in the movie blurs these
lines in a strange way the fur is hyper
realistic but the way it blends with the
faces of the actors is unsettling the
CGI also clearly outlines the shape of
the human bodies giving the females
shapes that only human women have there
were several rendering errors at one
point a cat's collar doesn't quite line
up old Deuteronomy
stretches a leg behind her head in a way
that doesn't look real at all there's a
huge use of green screens in the movie
sometimes it makes for a visual treat
but other times it's over-the-top and
the special effects have really strange
moments the cat that gets chosen to go
to have a side as
to heaven in a chandelier it really
doesn't make sense
catnip sprinkles critics seem to agree
that Taylor Swift was one of the bright
spots of the movie she plays bumble
arena she brings a genuine playfulness
and great vocals to the movie but her
storyline is problematic her character
is a femme fatale she is overly
suggestive and dances like she's in a
music video and she's addicted to
huffing catnip yes these cats appear to
have some addictive habits catnip can
make cats act inebriated and dazed it's
clear that bumble arena has a bit of a
substance problem this cat is also one
of the villains cronies she sympathizes
with Macavity a tough mean cat that
everyone fears here's where things get
uncomfortable she sprinkles cat dust on
anyone who doesn't agree with Macavity
in one scene we see her pour a bunch of
sparkly catnip over a whole crowd of
dancing cats while she lays is in a fake
crescent moon
that means she's putting other cats
under the influence without their
consent and we aren't sure exactly why
she does it
maybe she's just a little crazy or maybe
she thinks it will make them agree with
her appear at the things we love movies
more than anything for more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button and enable notifications check
your settings on mobile to allow YouTube
notifications and you'll never miss
another video
christabella much of cats is a
light-hearted movie with flashy upbeat
musical numbers there's a happiness in
most of the cats sometimes they're
teasing and flirty other moments they
have a childlike joy about the world
around them Rosabella is played by
Jennifer Hudson and there's no denying
she's talented she sings a gorgeous
rendition of memory but she comes across
so angry that it doesn't really match
the tone of the movie and Grizabella is
whole storyline is problematic she used
to be a glamour cat she was beautiful
and everyone wanted to be just like her
but she's fallen from grace
she lost her Sparkle and she's been
shunned by the Gela Cole's the movie
even suggests that she's fallen into a
certain type of adult work aren't he
supposed to be cats that aspect is
really disturbing she wants a new life
in heavy side more than just about
anyone else but she also just wants to
be accepted that's not the most
uncomfortable part of cats by any means
keep watching for the most fun
settling seen removable skin rebel
Wilson is one of the funniest parts of
the movie she plays Jenny Annie dots
she's somewhat lazy but she also rules
over the cockroaches in mice more on
them later in a lot of ways rebel feels
like she is playing herself while
looking like a cat but she definitely
provides some comic relief her dance
numbers are over the top she's always
getting into trouble
she falls a lot and she gets her paw paw
in a mousetrap
she wears snazzy outfits but that's one
of the problems one of the most
disturbing scenes in the movie comes
from Jenny any dots she appears to rip
off her skin to reveal a jazz outfit
we're pretty sure cats can't just remove
their fur and skin it was weird it's
even stranger than the fact that old
Deuteronomy wears a fur coat on top of
her actual fur we have so many questions
about that too is that the fur from
another cat these four issues bring a
terrifying level to the movie the cat
pens the movie is called cats it's all
about cats who want to go to heaven
the original musical was based on a lost
children's poem by TS Eliot and it was
about cats we get it but the movie
really leans into the cattiness of the
story first of all these actors are over
the top with their cat behavior they
hiss and lick themselves but then there
are just way too many cat pens of course
this isn't necessarily the movies fault
the original play has all the same lines
there are jokes about the cat getting
Victoria's tongue and letting the cat
out of the bag at first they're funny
they made us giggle because it's kind of
cute it shows that the movie isn't
taking itself too seriously but then it
became too much in a matter of minutes
the cat puns are annoying there are just
too many of them we think they could
have managed to cut quite a few of them
it wouldn't have ruined the effect of
the cat pens to have a few less weird
noises the movie might be about cats but
sometimes there are a few too many
reminders that these characters aren't
human we can't help but wonder if just
showing them looking like cats would be
enough instead the actors have a lot of
cat-like behaviors we don't just mean
moving and cat-like fashion either every
time James Corden's character bustopher
jones hisses it
uncomfortable and let's not forget about
ian mckellen of course he's an amazing
actor and he plays Gus the theater cat
who used to be a theatre legend but now
he's old and feeble Ian really took this
cat role seriously throughout the film
we see him lapping up milk from a bowl
the cats are just too human-like to pull
that scene off successfully it's
honestly kind of gross when any of the
cats eat it's a little nauseating
he also meows a lot very loudly none of
the actors sound really cat-like when
they meow it just makes the scenes weird
the mice and cockroaches cats didn't
include the creepiest part of the movie
in its trailers and for a good reason
the mice and cockroaches in the movie
are one of the most disturbing things
we've ever seen they look like they
belong in a horror movie
the humanoid face on the cockroaches
look like they've just been pasted on
then there are the mice they have
human-like faces too but it's extra
creepy because they look like children
as if this isn't bad enough we see the
cats eating these things and since you
never quite forget that these are humans
it all comes across very cannibalistic
seriously you haven't known disturbing
until you've seen James Corden eat a
mouse that looks like a child
additionally we see all these creatures
rummaging through the trash and eating
it it's not great for the appetite we
really have to wonder what the animators
are thinking with these creatures
especially the mice and cockroaches
which part of cats did you find the most
unsettling let us know in the comments
thank you for watching and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up we'll
catch you next time
you